heads up guys my name is a gentleman
welcome to the March update video so
good start to the year we've got some
videos going on sparky is going well
I've got turkey on the stove right now
everything is working out pretty well so
far so I wanted to make this update
video to share with you guys what I'm
going to do with the future right so I
kind of I've been focusing on dev vlogs
lately this year and that's because I've
been extremely busy um but on the other
hand I think that maybe you guys aren't
that interested in them I know that I
know that a lot of you like them but I
kind of myself like I was looking
through my channel and I kind of
realized that hey it's been a really
long time since I actually did some
tutorials and I kind of like I really
like teaching and I I just wanted to get
back to that so I wanted to know if you
guys agreed with me on that and the big
thing like I've started you probably
noticed the last night a on a
civilization series video went up and
there's actually one coming tomorrow
night as well that's already uploaded
and scheduled ready to go so I am kind
of gonna try and bang out some videos
here really quickly hopefully you in
fact hopefully you guys will see one per
day for like at least a week but
basically I want to know what you want
now the best thing to do in these cases
is to ask you and twitter has recently
come out with this pole system and they
used to have it so that you and me had
two options but now you can add as many
options as you like which is really
really cool so I thought that you know
what I'm gonna just tweet some polls and
we're going to figure out exactly what
you guys want to see so if you're not
following me on twitter twitter com for
surf the channel link is in the
description you're going to want to do
that because otherwise you'll start
missing things like this so if you want
to have your say and you want to know
what I'm up to and all that stuff then
very important follow me on Twitter okay
now that's other way let's take a look
at these polls so first of all I asked
you guys if you actually wanted to see
tutorials or if you were happy with dev
vlogs or if you wanted to see cats sorry
sixty-nine percent of you guys voted for
tutorials all right and there's like 127
votes here so anything over 100
think is pretty credible it's not like
three people voted for this so I feel
like this is generally a pretty good
sense of what you want to see and also
these polls run for 24 hours so it gives
pretty much everyone a good time to
actually to vote on them so yeah so
tutorials right like it's not like no
one enjoys the dev logs the cat's I'm
sure that people just voted for because
it was funny um I know I would have
probably voted for cats but um you know
dev logs are like I'll still keep
releasing them this is just kind of
maybe I should go back to tutorials so
that's good it's nine percent now second
poll what roles would you like to see so
these two categories 2d 3d I know that
they're kind of in the kind of subject
of graphics right and I didn't really
say that I would be doing graphics
tutorial per say but i just think the 2d
versus 3ds it's kind of I think it's
just a really good I don't know what I'm
saying I think it's just a really good
kind of subject matter to kind of
discuss in tutorials right so is this
like are we going to have some tutorials
on how to make 3d games we're going to
have such tutorials on how to make 2d
games because there's a fair there's a
fair difference so sixty-three percent
of you and this is 170 votes so quite a
bit more than the last one voted for um
for 3d tutorials okay so that's good
right you want tutorials and you want 3d
tutorials all right what about what
language you want them in C++ seems to
win that again these like getting closer
you can see that well this was
sixty-three percent is sixty-four
percent roughly two-thirds of you guys
are kind of voting here it's actually a
bit surprising to me to see how close
these are um there's no overwhelming
when a really apart from the first poll
really so it's it's definitely
interesting to see how how a lot of you
guys really do prefer like a like the
majority of you prefer a specific thing
but there are still a lot of people who
want the other thing which is terrible
for me right because it makes it makes
my job really difficult to make
something that everyone will like and no
one will comment being like hey what
about the other series where those video
so that's not great for me but hey like
the majority seem to once it was like 3d
C++ tutorials right and you can kind of
paste these poles together and see what
this is headed and then the final length
with the final poll which is actually
still going was already got 122 votes
with 12 hours left and 12 hours elapsed
and you can see that most people so far
at least in the poll want 10 to 20
minute videos so this tells me that you
guys want 10 to 20 minute c++ 3d
tutorials ok that's what's gonna happen
I guess I mean one of the things that I
really wanted to do on this channel that
I just never had the chance to is
actually do a series on how to make
games with OpenGL right because it's
just it's one of those things that I
never got around to doing that I really
want to i did that flappy bird series
and that was kind of meant to be a kind
of OpenGL hands-on type deal but that
ended up it just being a three-hour
video and it really wasn't about OpenGL
as much as just let's kind of get this
open gel stuff out of the way so that we
can make flappy bird so this could be an
opportunity for me to actually make a
proper series on hey let's learn OpenGL
in C++ obviously like I guess we would
be using C++ and not lwjgl it doesn't
matter what you use though because
OpenGL the fundamentals are going to be
exactly the same I'm sure someone could
put it to Java really really easily I
mean there are a few things to watch out
for and it actually is a bit worse with
lwjgl because there are some things you
have to get around like you have to keep
using all those buffer objects like byte
buffers and flowed buffers to actually
marshal dart across which is terrible
but it's still like fairly acceptable
and also like mapping buffers for
example is is not not very doable in
Java because there's no such thing as
memory addressing so yeah there's a few
things that I really don't like about
Java when it comes to that kind of
subject matter so yes c++ OpenGL
tutorials are what I'm thinking you guys
want to see right because that'll teach
you 3d that'll teach you C+ blood like
that'll be a C++ 3d tutorial
and each one of them will be between 10
to 20 minutes all right that seems to be
where you guys want is it is it leave a
comment below okay this is what this is
update this update video is for I want
to know what you guys think so just
leave a comment below and I'll try and
respond to as many comments as possible
if you guys have further questions or
requests I like no one not everyone's
going to be happy clearly like a third
of you wanted Java 2d tutorials right so
stuff like game programming which is
still continuing like I'm still doing
that civilization series which is in
Java which will slay it again into game
programming so this is by no means an
exclusive kind of contract that you're
signing right where you only get C++ 3d
videos this is just the priority of the
channel okay so this is these are the
videos that I will try my best to get
out and then if I have extra time I will
make other videos that's kind of what
this is about I will still keep making
Sparky dev logs though because they are
very easy to make they take me about a
total of maybe half an hour at like
maximum to do because there's no editing
I really judge chuck it in render it
it's done um and and and I don't even
have to like prepare for them at all i
just kind of show you guys what I'm up
to so dev logs were still continue don't
worry but in terms of tutorials and
stuff like that yeah like um it looks
like C++ 3d tutorials of what you guys
going to see okay so if you're happy
with that leave a comment if you're not
happy with that leave a comment let's
see what you guys think hopefully you
are happy with that and I can just do it
because first of all I really want to do
that so i probably will anyway in fact
and then once you know i do the c++
opengl tutorials i might do like I might
you know do the same series in Vulcan
and then maybe do the same series in
direct3d right I'll probably do it in a
few API so that you guys know how old
them work because I know how all them
work so I can like in it's actually not
that hard so I can't I can just kind of
show you guys exactly what you need to
know and my vision for this is we make a
small rendering engine and probably like
a renderer in fact yeah well we just
make a small renderer a small rendering
engine that
runs on you know these ap is so that you
guys know basically how you can write oh
yeah an engine right how you guys can
write some kind of abstraction layer on
top of OpenGL to just let you render
stuff like 3d models and like you know
have proper cameras and like lighting
conditions and like materials and all
that stuff alright if you enjoy this
video please hit like button please
leave a comment with your thoughts and I
will see you guys next time goodbye